the sign is the same but there's
something radically different about the
store underneath it's in the pedestrian
city center not a suburban parking lot
that means no car to ferry your Goods
home meet Nikolas my colleague in the
German city of Hamburg
he's on paternity leave and as you can
see has his hands full I'm gonna try to
lighten his load by proving or
disproving that you can do an Ikea shop
without four wheels that means public
transportation and then a short walk the
store one of three and Homburg and 49 in
germany is an expensive bet for the
swedish company it's 25% smaller than
most stores and was almost twice as
expensive to build it's between 40 and
50 million for a normal sized blue box
on the potato field here we are more
than what we invested more than 80
million euro we knew from the beginning
that in Hamburg we had more than 43
percent of people without cars if you
look at the store in champers off in
Berlin or investing back we know that
between 20 and 30 percent of the people
come without cars
so I have my colleagues essentials now
how do I get them home IKEA is offering
these transport lights to help inner
city dwellers they're free for the first
three hours if you're helpless they'll
even help you load up and then you're
off it is a little tippy I don't know if
I'm Road legal or not I'm and best to
maybe avoid standoffs with cars
I think they respect me plus I've got a
bow breaks brick frick frick breaks okay
are you I'm good to see you
okay we've got some more chatter okay
uh you're on your own for assembly I got
to get that bike back
you got your helper well we made it we
proved that you can do a big IKEA shop
without a car but next time I think I'll
take a taxi